From Warner bros and their former bro. Yeah.
It's sort of not how you treat filmmakers and stars.
Becomes a film about technology that reverses the flow of time that no one
wishes was real. So we could have released the movie four months earlier,
Tenant experience. What happens when a filmmaker goes so far up his own,
but that everything gets inverted.
Two antagonists, one in verdict and machine.
She shot when an inverted Brown you are in Virginia blue team,
inverted thought you were inverted kind of stabilize the invest radiation by
inverting.
That would take twice the number of memento plot dogs to properly explain.
That's basically the end of the amendment, but.
Basically some people and objects are moving backwards in time.
The people moving forwards in time can interact with them.
And everyone's buddy to control a big mess, stab that blessed the past.
Did you still get lost? Don't worry. So to the cat.
Sometimes the logic teacher to catch up to what I believe he would feel in the
moment, even if I can't all the way, explain what it was. You know,
it's not even a question of getting everything or even anything.
I think my last question is saying, am I alive or dead?
Critics have taken no into task for as overbanked plots under developed
characters and all white heroes. Well,
he's addressed one of those things. Denzel Washington,
sun stars, as the protagonist, a mysterious secret, um,
protagonist to, uh, look, he's a protagonist. Okay.
That's all you're going to get.
I'm the protagonist he's joined by Neil of fellow time cop.
Who's the bill two protagonists, Ted.
Let we get up to some stuff. You're going to love it, dude.
You guys are going to go back in time. Yeah. You are going to have the books.
Excellent adventure, or you never did tell me who recruited you, Neil.
You did, or you guys were, you did.
No way backs who continues the grand Nolan tradition of largely
mute children. You only see the hero of cat a woman's so tall.
She could drive a car from the backseat.
Michael Kane as himself must have my car. Sure. Why not? And sate of vodka,
swilling arms dealer.
Who's an Adidas tracksuit away from checking off every evil Russian stereotype.
Tell me about the radiation on the receptor.
Taking plutonium from the rebel of my city as a teenager.
Well, he's not the most over the top Russian I've seen.
So I guess he earned his paycheck, paid that men,
his money pushed through this extremely dense and intricate way of telling an
unsatisfying hollow spy story that feels like the movie adaptation of a
crossword puzzle because it kind of is.
And when you strip away the mind-bending Saifai concept and parse through the
hard to hear dialogue [inaudible].
Private place and managed to stay.
Awake through all of the meetings.
It's just a backdrop for rich people doing time crimes to each other,
like a Rube Goldberg machine that ends with you getting kicked in the nuts is
your.
Head, Hey yet? Yes.
Thrill as Nolan.
Rediscovers the backwards action thinking from that spike Jones video and the
backwards talking thing from that Missy Elliot song, as he in the cast,
pull off the incredible fee of filming huge sequences in reverse that in theory
sound like they reinvent the genre,
but just looks like they chose the rehearsal takes of them,
practicing the choreography.
And what's less of a mind and more of just a frustrating chore to make sense of
like someone inverted your controls on GTA.
So suit up once again, just not in that off the rack,
poor person kind of way Brooks previs for what may not be no one
at his best,
but it definitely is no one at his most that exaggerates everything you either
love or hate about his films.
And if you're a no-win worshiper who wants to rewatch something three times
before, it makes sense more power to you. I just hope, you know,
you also have to pretend to love Tokyo drift to what do you like about fast and
furious? I'm sort of original recipe kind of original. Um,
but I I've got a very soft spot for Tokyo drift. Actually.
Of course he loves Tokyo drift.
It's the one that completely messed up the timeline story.
Let's just put the protagonist here for now and come up with something better
later. Tinker time, Lord soldier, spy.
What if let Amir Putin looked like Harvey Weinstein and as a picky picky, wild,
wild, fat burly eyes,
moody Dench and how no one writes a character.
No small talk, nothing that might reveal who we are or what we do.
A man, a plan, a canal, Panama, Whoa.
You know, if I were inverted, I just pooped in front of my enemies.
So they have to watch it materialize on the floor.
Then shoots up into my butt cheeks. That'd be awesome.
I am an industrial welder tented movie was inspired by master
Yoda dialogues.
That's my bike punk blue to UNE balloons,
blue to few goons to the new moon.
Have yourself a Merry Christmas.